this conference was about promoting
tourism in a nearly bankrupt country but
instead lebanese prime minister
najimikati had to address a crisis
threatening his two-month-old government
saudi arabia and some arab gulf
countries have severed ties with lebanon
for what they see as an increasing
dominance of the hezbollah armed group
we are determined to restore ties with
saudi arabia and gulf states i'm
repeating my calls for the information
minister to listen to his conscience and
put circumstances into consideration and
take the stance he should take this is
the priority of the solution to get out
of the crisis
the latest dispute was triggered by the
comments of information minister george
kordaje who called the yemen war a saudi
aggression it's a difficult balancing
act for a prime minister who wants to
restore ties with the country's
traditional economic and political
partners but whose cabinet is controlled
by hezbollah and its allies they have
publicly backed the minister who has
reiterated his refusal to resign
he also needs to
gain a consensus
and agreements of hezbollah and animal
movement the two shiite political
parties as well as the merida party the
party of the minister kardashian
is not to resign as well if
kardashian
the diplomatic dispute is aggravating
divisions in lebanon which is among the
battlefields where iran and saudi
arabia's geopolitical tug of war is
played out
the lebanese government must offer a
clear and frank apology to saudi arabia
and the gulf states and starts a real
dialogue to address controversial issues
that includes ending hezbollah's
military intervention in yemen
saudi arabia has long accused hezbollah
of helping the iran-backed houthi rebels
in yemen a charge the group denies
saudi arabia is pressuring lebanon to
take a harsher line on hezbollah but the
lebanese foreign minister has said the
kingdom is forcing impossible terms on
the government hezbollah he says is a
component of lebanese politics and its
armed wing has a regional dimension
which can't be resolved by the
authorities here
already cabinet has been deadlocked for
weeks after a dispute about the judge
investigating last year's blast at
beirut port and now without support from
gulf nations it will be hard to secure
much needed international aid to stop
its economic collapse senator al jazeera
beirut